the modern synthesis is not usually
mentioned in textbooks but when reading
reports on the history of science you'll
often see the modern synthesis described
as a merger between evolution by natural
selection with mandilon genetics widely
popularized starting in the 1940s the
modern synthesis is what we call a
research program it was a set of popular
interests that were guiding researchers
as they decided what was worth studying
one of the extremely impressive
achievements often associated with the
modern synthesis was the mathematical
formalization of evolution by natural
selection so Darwin's somewhat messy
ideas were translated into precise
mathematical equations